المترجم: Samir abojabl
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
سأنطق بعض الكلمات ولنرى
مدى تأثيرها عليكم إن شاء الله،
وأجزم أن البعض منكم
سيتفاعل مع هذه الكلمات.
كويا، كسوكونجي، توندي، كيوموتو
يوجد بعض التفاعل، إنها أسماء غريبة
وشخص مثلي بمعية طائرة ويرتدي ملابساً
غريبة ويتحدث بهذه الطريقة.
حقيقةً، كل هذه المناطق التي ذكرتها تقع
في شمال السودان،
مناطق غير معروفة للكثيرين ومخفيّة
ويتّصف أهلها بالطيبة والكرم
والاحتكاك بهم يكسبك الكثير من المعارف
والعديد من الأشياء
قد لا تجدها في الخرطوم أو المدن الحضرية.
هذه تجربتنا في منطقة الشمالية.
نحن مجموعة من الشباب، البعض
منهم معنا هنا الآن،
نسبه للظروف المعيشية والضغوط،
والبحث الدائم عن تحقيق الآمال،
والأهداف والمسؤوليات،
ولتغطية العائد المادي الضئيل في السودان،
ذهبنا إلى مناطق الذهب في شمال السودان.
ولنشاهد جزء من تجربتنا في منطقة بعيدة،
منطقة غير مشهورة ولا نسمع عنها.
كانت تجربتنا في شمال السودان في المناطق
التي ذكرتها وكلها مناطق غنية بالذهب.
ما شدّ انتباهنا هو إنسان هذه المنطقة،
أو إنسان هذه المناطق في الولاية الشمالية
والذي لا يشعر أحد بوضعه،
ولم يوجد شخص قريب منه
ليعكس مستوى المعيشة اليومي الذي يحياه.
نعم، هم شعب طيب ومسالم
لم يفعلوا شيئاً لإظهار نفسهم للعالم،
لكنهم يعانون من مشاكل أساسية
وهو ما تسبّب لنا بالألم ودفعني
للتحدث إليكم اليوم.
نعاني من مشكلة التصحر،
التصحر وتقلّص المراعي
لمن لا يعرف ما هو التصحر
دعونا نشاهد هذا الفيديو القصير من إنتاجنا
وصور مأخوذة من الطبيعة.
(فيديو)
فيديو قصير يوضح أن المنازل
أصبحت ممتلئة بالرمال،
الأراضي الزراعية تقلّصت
ولا يوجد مراعي
أولئك الأشخاص الذين يمارسون الزراعة والرعي
لا يستطيعون ممارسة نشاطهم في الشمالية
لأن الرمال طمرت المنازل.
يهاجرون إلى السعودية وخلال سنة يعود أحدهم
ليجد منزله قد امتلأ حتى منتصفه بالرمال.
تخيل منزلاً به أطفال ومكونات أسرة كاملة
يُطْمَرْ حتى منتصفه بالرمال
فيصبح مضطراً أن يبني طابقاً جديداً
أو أن يرحل إلى مكان جديد.
بغض النظر عن فقدان أرضه الزراعية
وهي مساحه صغيرة مزروعة بالبطيخ
لمقابلة متطلبات المعيشة اليومية.
نسينا أمر الذهب واتجهنا الي التفكير
في ما يمكن عمله لمساعدة هؤلاء الأشخاص.
مصطلح التصحّر معروف عالمياً ويقول
بعض العلماء أن المقصود به السودان بالتحديد
أكثر منطقة بها تصحّر وتقلّص
مراعي هي السودان.
الحل بأن يحارب التصحّر
بزراعة أنواع معينة من الأشجار
بسرعة، هذه الأشجار تسمى الأكاشيا،
منها الصمغ العربي والهجليج...الخ
تتم زراعة هذه الأشجار بالطريقة التقليدية
بمعينات يدوية ونثر للبذور.
ماذا أضفنا نحن؟
مشروعنا يسمي SAP
Smart Agriculture Payload
يستخدم الطائرات بدون طيار في خدمة الإنسان
عن طريق جعل هذه الطائرات بدون طيار التي
تستخدم في أفغانستان وأمريكا لقتل البشر
اليوم عوضاً عن زراعة الصواريخ
ستزرع بذور النباتات.
هذا هو مشروع SAP
(تصفيق)
أول نموذج لطائرة بدون طيار
لها قدره ذاتية على اتخاذ القرار
عبارة عن رجل آلي طائر تقوم
بالعمليات الزراعية
بمساعدة حمولة بدلاً من أن تكون قنبلة
أو صاروخ اليوم هي حمولة للخير.
(تصفيق)
(فيديو)
نحن في قسم التطوير للمؤسسة التطوعية
نحن مطورون لتطبيقات آلية
بحراً وبراً وجواً بنظام آلي
لتحقيق تأثير مباشر على الاقتصاد
والإبداع المجتمعي في مناطق إفريقيا الخلوية
(موسيقى)
يعاني هؤلاء الناس من التصحّر
وتقلّص المراعي
وإنتاج القليل من الطعام كمياً
ونوعياً والمزيد.
بعد سنتين من البحث والتطوير وقلة الموارد،
أتينا بجهاز آلي
لتصبح الزراعة في إفريقيا أكثر ذكاءً
ومحصورةً أكثر فيما يسمى بالزراعة الذكيّة.
(موسيقى)
نستطيع أن نستكشف الأرض
لمساحه حوالي 300 فدان
في مهمة ساعة واحدة من الطيران البطيء،
بنفس الطريقه نستخدم التصوير الفتوغرافي
لرسم الخرائط بمؤشر NDVI
ويستخدم أيضاً لتقييم الصحة النباتية.
(موسيقى)
(تصفيق)
تستطيع الطائرة حمل مختلف أنواع البذور
بمختلف أنواع شجر الأكاشيا
وأن تقطع مسافة طويلة جداً بطيران بطيء
نستطيع من خلالها زراعة كل القرى
التي ذكرتها آنفا بغابات من شجر الأكاشيا
وتحديداً الصمغ العربي
وأيضاً ليكون مصدر دخل إضافي لمواطن المنطقة
بدلاً من زراعة أشياء بسيطة يصبح له قدرة
الحصول على دخل أجنبي من خلال الصمغ العربي.
إن سمحت له الحكومة بذلك.
(ضحك)
سأتحدث بسرعة ومن ناحية تقنيّة أكثر.
ينقسم SAP الي قسمين:
القسم الأول قاذف للبذور
والقسم الثاني جزء مخصص باستخدام
تقنية جديدة في العالم اسمها NDVI
وهي موشر الغطاء النباتي
ومن خلالها نستطيع أن نعرف صحة النبات
في حالة المشاريع ذات المساحات الشاسعة
كمثال عمليه التمثيل الضوئي وكمية
الكلوروفيل داخل النبات.
بالنظر لهذا النموذج، هذه كاميرا معدّلة
وجزء كبير منها مصنّع في السودان
على أيدي شباب سودانيين، لا يتوفر لهم مال
ولا أي دعم خارجي.
يصنعون بأيديهم واعتمادً على الإنترنت
ومن دون مال أو إمكانيات
ومن دون انتظار دعم من أحد،
لا تنتظر دعماً من أحد مطلقاً.
اجتهد واتعب، حتى إن دعا الأمر أن تبيع
بيتك أو سيارتك كما فعلت أنا ولكن اجتهد.
(تصفيق)
هنا شكل الجهاز، النظام القاذف بالداخل
مهمته رمي البذور علي الأرض
طبّقنا بعض المفاهيم الخاصة بالزراعة
مثل الزراعة عن بعد والزراعة الذكية،
وكيفية إتمام عملية الزراعة باستخدام
نظام تحديد المواقع،
تحتوي بعض الأجهزة على نظام تحديد المواقع
وبها نظام أقمار صناعية لتحديد النقاط،
تقلع الطائرة آلياً فتعرف أين تزرع وأين
تنتهي دون تدخّل الإنسان فقط في المتابعة.
يمثل هذا مفهوم الزراعة الذكية
للطائرات من دون طيار.
والأمر الثاني: الخرائط الجويّة
خرائط تحدد نوع النبات والحوجة للماء
إذا كان به نسبة عطش أو نسبة أمراض،
كل هذا عن طريق نظام التصوير الجوي
المخصص للأغراض الزراعية NDVI
هذه صورة لنبات التقطتها في المنزل
التقطتها لنبات في المنزل وليس
في مزرعة مثلاً.
نلاحظ أن الجزء العلوي لونه أخضر
وحسب الخرطة الجينية
يدل هذا علي أن عملية التمثيل
الضوئي ممتازة جداً،
والأطراف باللون المائل للأحمر
لا تتم فيها عمليه تمثيل ضوئي.
يساعدنا هذا النظام في تحليل النبات
واكتشاف ما إذا كان مريضاً وهكذا.
المزارع نفسه يمكنه التعامل مع هذه التقنية
وتحليل محصوله دون الحوجة لخبير زراعي.
سنشاهد فيديو بسرعة يتحدث عن المشروع.
(فيديو)
إنها فرصة عظيمة لتسليط الضوء
علي مشاكل التنمية الاقتصادية
وتأثرها المباشر بالتصحّر وتقلّص المراعي
استنادً على الدعم الفني من المجتمع
والدعم الشخصي
طورنا نظاماً للتغلب
علي التصحّر وتقلّص المراعي
وذلك بتصنيع SAP
لأداء حصاد آلى ونظام زراعي آلي
للاستشعار عن بعد
استطعنا أن نصنع SAP كنظام ذكي محمول جواً،
على متن نطاق جوي عالي.
سيؤثر هذا البحث والمشروع التنموي
إيجاباً علي التنمية الاقتصادية
وأسلوب المعيشة في الضواحي.
وذلك بزراعة عدد من حبوب أشجار الأكاشيا
مثل الصمغ العربي.
سيحدّ ذلك من التصحر
وفي نفس الوقت إنتاج الصمغ العربي.
يعطي نظام SAP صوراً متعددة
لتقييم صحة النبات ومراقبة
المحاصيل والتحليل.
عادةً لا نستطيع تقييم صحة النبات
بالعين المجردة
خصوصاً في المناطق الزراعية
والمشاريع الكبيرة.
تتعقب هذه التقنيات العوامل
التي تؤثر علي نمو النبات،
مثل درجه الحرارة والرطوبة.
هذا النظام المحمول جواً يتكون من:
بصريات ومستشعرات تعمل بالتزامن،
مستخدمةً تقنية استشعار للرؤية،
تقوم بجمع الصور ومعالجتها وارسالها
لوحدة معالجة مضمنة.
يمكنها كذلك إعطاء نتائج دقيقة
للمتابعة والعمليات الزراعية
بناءً علي الموارد المتاحة واستخدام
المعلومات
للتحكم في المشاريع والإشراف العام.
تمكن أيضاً المزارعين من تمييز النبات الذي
ينمو بصوره جيدة وتصحيح الري والسماد للتربة
(تصفيق)
هنا النموذج الأولي الذي نعمل عليه
حالياً وسمينا المزارع الذكي
وهو عبارة عن أول رجل الي يقوم
بعمليات الزراعة الدقيقة
وينزل إلي الأرض محمول جواً
سترونه قريباً بإذن الله.
هذه إحدى مشاركاتنا
طرقنا أبواب العديد من المؤسسات السودانية
لتساعدنا ولتقديم الدعم لهذا المشروع
لذلك أضعنا الكثير جداً من الوقت
في هذه المحاولات.
اعتمدنا علي مواردنا الشخصية ولم نتعذر
بأن هذه التقنية متوفرة فقط للأمريكيين.
بدأنا نبحث في أشياء مثل اللوحات الأم
القديمة وأجهزة المذياع والخلاطات،
ولقد كنا في منافسة مع أكبر الدول والشركات
المصنعة للطائرات بدون طيار
وقد كانت فرصة لتغيير وجه السودان بالخارج
لدول ظنت أننا بعيدين عن التقنية
وإلي الآن نعاني من مشاكل تعليم وصحة
ومأكل ومشرب
لكن رغم ذلك نتحدث الآن عن تقنية،
وأنظمة آليّة بصورة واقعية
نحن الآن نوظّف التقنية لتساعدنا في مأكلنا
ومشربنا ولتقدم لنا خدمة حقيقية.
(تصفيق)
وهذا ليس تفاخراً منا أمام الوزير
أو الرئيس بما فعلناه أو حتى مجرد أحلام،
هذه الطائرة أثّرت وأسهمت حقاً في حل
مشاكل إنسان يعاني من مشاكل عدة
ليس فقط من أجل الدعاية أو الإعلام.
مقر عملنا هو شقة بمنزلنا كانت معرض
لوحات لوالدي عليه الرحمة
جزء منه ورشة مخصصة للتصنيع والتركيب
وهؤلاء هم أخوتي وزملائي شركاء النجاح.
هنا في دبي، نعمل على تصنيع أنظمتنا
هنا نظام SAP
هنا الرجل الآلي المصغّر
الذي تحدثت عنه قبل قليل.
نحن هنا وسط كبار المصنعين
للطائرات بدون طيار
وعلماء في مجال الطيران والأنظمه الذكية
والرجل الآلي كنا في مشاركة معهم.
(موسيقي)
ماذا نفعل حالياً؟
حالياً، نوظف طائرتنا
وكل امكانياتنا وخبراتنا.
مجال دراستي هو هندسة الطيران ومهتم بمجال
الحوسبة المتقدمة والطائرات بدون طيار
نوظف كل خبرتنا المكتسبة من السفر والدراسة
في الخارج لصالح خدمة المشاريع الزراعية.
حالياً نحن بصدد مشروع مع
شركة سكر النيل الأبيض
لمسح كل المشاريع الخاصة بقصب السكر
وهذه إحدى مشاريعنا.
لدي كلمة أخيرة وهي كلمة مهمة جداً.
هذه صورة لأطفال في آخر شريحة عرض لدي.
أريد أن أقول لكل الشباب هنا ومن خلال
منصة TEDx ومجهود دكتور أنور.
أن نركّز على الأثر المباشر
علي إنسان المنطقة
المشاريع التي تمسّ المواطنين
ومنازلهم وأطفالهم وحياتهم اليومية
حتى نؤثّر ونغيّر فيها.
وقدوتنا في ذلك شباب TEDx وشارع
الحوادث ومبادرة نفير وغيرهم
التغيير يتم عن طريق العمل والتركيز
على الأشياء المهمة،
هناك العديد من الأشياء ولكن أهمها التي
تؤثر علي أبي وأخي وخالتي وعمتي وجاري.
مشاريع ذات أثر مباشر عليهم.
وشكراً لكم.
(تصفيق)